le président de la République française
a parlé à Pif Gadget si si ce n'est pas
une blague il a donné une interview le
20 février interrogé par des jeunes
lecteurs pour les 75 ans du magazine
fais ce frotter les yeux pour lire cette
dépêche qui est tombée à 6h du matin et
manuel Macron a accordé un entretien ou
jeune lecteur de Big gadget alors je
vais quand même vous citer une interview
excuse-moi qu'il a donné à Pif le chien
bons débats en plateau la nouvelle
suicide bon nombre de critiques sur les
réseaux sociaux beaucoup soulignent que
le chef de l'État a préféré parler à Pif
le chien qu'à l’inter syndical sur la
réforme des retraites au milieu des
montages photos et vidéos
certains ironisent sur le gadget que
l'on trouvait avant dans le magazine en
imaginant cette fois un CRS ou une bombe
lacrymogène faut arrêter aussi de dire
que Bruno voudrait qu'on tape les flics
c'est pas vrai
une fidèle des GG qui nous appelle des
Alpes-Maritimes bonjour Valérie
est-ce que est-ce que ça va est-ce que
je peux pas je peux pas c'est vrai
il dit moi je veux que ce soit les
patrons de restaurant comptable moi je
peux pas accepter ça si tout le monde
était agélase
on rirait tout le temps ou on ferait la
tronche tout le temps
[Musique]
oui bien sûr
mais je vais faire dehors je les adore
mais non c'est le contraire on ferait la
gueule tout le temps si on était à Gélas
le terme ça signifie une personne qui ne
rit jamais ça j'accepte pas
c'est une vanne pourrie ton truc je te
le dis non non je fais pas de 22 jambes
moi je dis pas faut taper les Bruno
poncés dans les manifestations je ne le
dirai jamais parce que non seulement je
le dirai jamais mais je le pense pas bah
ouais mais moi non plus mais tu vois
faut arrêter de dire que moi je suis
pour qu'on t'appeler flic même si je les
aime pas plus que ça moi je pense pas
que c'est ce que j'ai pas dit que tu
étais j'ai dit que tu ne condames pas
les violences
contre des fonctionnaires de police ce
n'est pas pareil on apprend que le
personnage de BD préféré du Président
c'est Lucky Luke qu'enfant il avait un
doudou un lapin qui l'a perdu et que
devenir président n'était pas un rêve
d'infos
[Musique]
il y avait un reportage sur France 2
récemment amusant dans lequel on
interroge une bourgeoise à bicyclette à
vélo pas trottinette pas trottinette
quand même attention
vous êtes Franconville c'est ça c'est ça
et vous allez faire ce qu'on fait quand
on est stressé à trois on crie très fort
1 2 3
c'est le meilleur de tous les cris de
toute l'histoire de slam
[Musique]
é
à ce que penser les électeurs Macron de
la présidentielle et alors elle commence
son propos en disant j'avoue que j'ai
voté Emmanuel Macron j'avoue tout est
dans le j'avoue aujourd'hui c'est le 24
% des Français pensent qu'Emmanuel
Macron est un bon président reste
évidemment à s'accorder sur ce qu'est un
bon ce que serait un bon président en
tout cas ils sont que 15% le jugeait
capable de rassembler les Français ce
qui est intéressant et ce qui est
nouveau dans cette étude c'est la façon
dont le cœur de son électorat est en
train de prendre ses distances en
quelque sorte en tout cas on voit que
les convaincus de la première heure le
son de moins en moins comme disait
Richard cœur de lion a vaincre sans
péril en triomphe sans gloire
19% des électeurs d'Emmanuel Macron du
premier tour regrette leur vote et ne
ferait pas le même choix aujourd'hui
tout commence la semaine dernière
lorsque le président de la République
s'apprête à prendre la parole sur TF1 et
France 2 une habitante du Pas-de-Calais
décide alors de publier ce message sur
les réseaux sociaux
va parler demain à 13h mais quelques
jours plus tard trois policiers se
présentent chez elles après ce message
injurieux la femme peine toujours à y
croire je leur ai demandé si c'était une
blague c'est la première fois que je
suis arrêtée
au fond de cette boîte chante les
sardines chante les sardines ah
qu'est-ce qu'on est serré au fond de
cette boîte Jean de les salines entre
lui et les arômes
je sais tu es sans voix c'est la peur
qui monte
mais la terre n'est pas une blague plus
qu'elle a bien été placée en garde à vue
et sera jugé au tribunal pour outrage et
insultes envers le président et risque
jusqu’à 6 mois de prison et 22500 euros
d'amende en ce moment on l'a lu dans la
presse le gouvernement cherche une idée
de génie pour sortir de la crise ils ont
qu'à aller chez GIFI
excellent en Smart merci à tous le
président accuse la France insoumise de
vouloir délégitimer les institutions
donc il a répondu poliment à la première
si le président de la République veut
faire de la pub à Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
puis s'adresser à lui directement qu'il
le fasse vous pourrez aussi demander à
Gérald Darmanin que s'est-il passé à
droite à droite à laquelle il a
appartenu
mais vous vous êtes trahi vous-même le
RPR c'est trahi une réponse gardez-la
pour vous parce que
il a été un peu plus saoulé à la
deuxième je pense que c'est à lui qu'il
faut poser la question et il a trouvé
une punchline pour en finir et on vous
le on vous la livre en exclu
je vais pas répondre à la place de la
France insoumise ou les inviterez un
point de vue ouais mais ne mélangeons
pas tout pouvez-vous quitter votre poste
en plein mandat et comment ça se
passerait si vous le quittiez lui
demande Mélina qui est une élève de 4e
ce n'est pas mon souhait si tu le
quittes c'est qu'il peut y avoir une
énorme crise et que tu es empêché à ce
moment-là tu remets ton mandat au
français et le peuple vote à nouveau le
président Macron n'exclut donc pas de
partir un jour sans retour et effacer
son amour sans se retourner ne pas
regretter penser à demain recommencer
partir pourquoi pas pour colomber les
deux églises qu'aimes-tu dans ton métier
lui a demandé un jeune lecteur l'échange
lui a répondu Emmanuel Macron l'échange
avec lui-même peut-être les choses avec
lui-même sans doute si maintenant
président de la République donne des
infos importantes dans la presse
jeunesse ou spécialisée ça va se
compliquer petite astuce pour que tout
le monde comprenne tout du contexte
actuel et ne loupe rien je me suis
procuré le plan presse du Président il
dévoilera le plan immigration dans le
Journal de Mickey puis détaillera ses
projets pour la France dans Cheval
Magazine et enfin il adressera un
message d'apaisement au syndicat dans
pêche de mer voilà madame borne prendra
la parole ces prochaines heures dans la
strappy Bruno Le Maire dans Fripounet et
géraldman et Gérald Darmanin nous sommes
le 29 mars 2022 bonjour les petits
enfants